Talking about text, if you really want
to reduce the number of file requests
your page makes,
you can inline images using code.
Two ways to do that, SVG and DataURIs.
Now here's a vector graphic
you may have seen before.
Both versions look identical, and
here they are in emulation mode.
And here on a real phone.
Looking at the page source, you'll see
that the logos are declared inline.
There's an SVG and
an image element with a data URI source.
Inline SVG has great support on
mobile and desktop browsers, and
optimization tools can
significantly reduce SVG size.
Spot the difference, these two
inline SVG logos look identical, but
one is around 3 kilobytes and
the other only about 2k.
SVG is incredibly powerful.
Check out this interactive version of
Trajan's Column, works on mobile too.
And the best thing,
all that responsive interactivity for
less that 160 kilobytes.
For more amazing SVG examples,
check out the link below the video.
Data URIs provide a way to include
a file such as an image inline as
a base64 encoded string
using the following format.
The full version is
around 5,000 characters.
Just like SVG, Data URIs
are well supported on mobile and
desktop browsers.
That's around well,
nearly 97% of browsers.
So you can inline images in your HTML,
but
Data URIs and
SVGs can also be inlined in CSS.
Works on desktop and on mobile.
Here we have two identical looking
images implemented as background images
in CSS, one data URI and one SVG.
Now the code looks a bit crazy so
why would you want to do this?
Well, to reduce HTTP requests.